In 49 minutes. Jesus Christ. What I do that for the next 11 minutes? Uh.
It is what it is.
Um, Oh, I have to, you know, what I have to do is, Oh, I got to tell you,
remember, I told you that story last week about my dad and about the nude ma the
nude clippings that I had,
he heard it and he told me you forgot some parts.
And so I should fill in the parts.
So I here is the updated version from my dad.
My dad already kind of had an inkling about it because my buddy Matra Vinny
called me a few days before that and said, Hey, Mr. Dalea is Chris there?
And I picked it up.
And when I picked it up before my dad hung up the phone Matra van and said,
you want to go see the pictures? And my dad hung up the phone and was like,
I wonder what thought about. Right? So
the,
the kid came over and told on me and my dad said so.
And he said, yes. So I just don't know. I wanted to tell you.
And my dad said, yeah, so now I know now what?
And the kid said, well, I don't know.
And that was good because my dad is a boss player. Now, afterwards,
my dad,
cause he went to see the picture and make sure there was no animal or anything
said, well, look, if you really want to see, uh,
see, uh, a beautiful naked woman look at this.
And he had, uh, a foot,
his friend was a photographer named Marco Glavine out, eh,
say Italian,
his name was [inaudible]. Okay. Eh, straight up said Italian. So he, um,
he was like, uh,  he, Oh
, he would photograph naked women like in a beautiful way, black and white with, it all
look like, you know, film noir. And uh,  he said, look at this
, look at this. And my dad starts opening the pages, showing me these beautiful women nude models and not the girl who I was looking at with fried butterflies and, and big
melons
. My buddy in high school used to say Jimbo, and I'd be like, what's that? And he'd say,
[inaudible].
Dude. Oh, what a.
Goofball. So, um, anyway, uh,
so he shows me these, this book,
this photography book that Mark Laviano did and all these women,
beautiful women. And I look and I'm like the wee baby. And I'm like, Oh,
this is a woman. Right. And my dad and I, my dad said,
I looked at him and I said, I said,
does mom know you have this?
And he was like, yeah, yeah, no.
I thought he was like confiding in me that, Oh. All right,
I'll keep it. Cool. I won't tell mom,
you have this photo book of Marco Gloriana anyway,
dude, I would go in and I would look at that every after,
after that I remember I would go in and I would look at it when my dad wasn't in
his office. And sometimes I show my friends. That's crazy,
man. It's crazy how the you remember, you know?
And it's crazy to think when you have a kid that like my kid
is going to have that, those moments
and he's going to have moments of Oh,
like that, just that you remember,
and some of them are gonna be important to some of them aren't, you know,
like I remember one time I was a preschool pre-K or whatever the
and this girl, I was eating wafers. Those, those, those wafers,
I always would have these vanilla wafers. I loved them do it.
My mom wouldn't get them enough, you know?
And I was eating them and then she was eating her, whatever dessert was,
it was dessert time, you know?
And she was eating the wafers and taking the smallest
bites, the smallest bites. Now we were both small,
but she was taking the smallest bites. And I was like,
looking at her while I was eating the F bro. I shovel in my mouth.
I don't even use my hands sometime. I just go like this. And I'm like,
and then move forward on the table. As I chomp
along, it's like,
it's like a conveyor belt at the end of a horror movie where somebody was like,
no, no, they get smashed in the head anyway. That's my,
that's how the food's getting into my mouth. I don't,
there's always going to be food. People say, why do you eat so fast?
Because I always want the food in my mouth. The second I swallow it,
I put more food in my mouth. Cause the sensation is the best in the mouth.
I don't want to swallow, wait a little bit and just suck on air.
I want to eat the and it tastes good. And yum, yum. It tastes good.
And yum, yum. It tastes good.
And then I swallow it and then I put another piece in my mouth because,
because it's sensation because it's,
and this girl was eating the smallest bites. And in my little head,
I was like, Oh, you know, how old are you when you go to pre-K?
I don't know for, I don't know, younger. I three,
I, uh, I was like,
am I going to say something to this girl? Am I going to at? Cause what,
what is she doing?
She needs to know that she has to have more of the food in her mouth
to hit all the taste buds. And then when she swallow,
she needs to put another mouthful in there.
So it's at maximum fun capacity in our mouth. You understand?
This is the I was breaking down as a three-year-old and she's chomping little
nibble mouse bites. And I look at her and now I can't help myself.
Cause I'm like, I gotta say something. Cause I gotta know what the she's doing.
I gotta know why she's doing it because I am I going to teach her how to eat?
Like, what's the deal. She was younger than me too. I remember. And I say, Hey.
And she says, yeah, I bet she was so cute.
Even as a three-year-old she was maybe two. And I was like, Oh, she's so cute.
But she was, I was like, why taking such small bites?
And she looked at me and she says, because then it lasts longer.
And I couldn't really argue with that. You know,
she taught me and I thought I was going to teach.
Her.
So the moral of the story is a two year old can teach a three-year-old
something, but I still take monster bites,
dude. I've never taken a small bite. But my point is,
I think of that all the time.
I think of it all the time. I don't know who that girl is.
I don't remember her name. I think she was Mexican or something.
Maybe Puerto Rican because we were on the East coast. But dude,
I think about it all the time.
I think about it often when I'm eating while I'm taking my big bites,
you never know what's going to shape you. It could be the Nudie magazines.
It could be the small bites to the girl sitting next to you,
but that's what makes you who you are. And that's beautiful, dude.
That's beautiful. Uh,
yeah, I remember what she said that too. I thought, Oh,
I'd rather it go quick and just get the maximum phone capacity in my mouth.
Uh, because of.
Sensation, sensation, sensation.
Um, being a kid was the man
being a kid was the.
I guess you'd get to relive those moments. You know, when you have a kid,
I hope so. That would be very cool. Very nice and very special.